نجم يونايتد السابق يختفي الانظار في
هولندا كونتي ينسى همومه في باريس وسوره
نابولي يعود للاحتفال بلقب الدوري هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من العربيه
الرياضه اهلا بكم
خطف نجم مانشستر يونايتد السابق الاضواء
بعد فوز فريقه
في نهائي مسابقه الكاس حساب نادي على
تويتر نشر مقطع فيديو
وهو يرقص في غرفه الملابس الخاصه بفريقه
بعد فوزه باول لقب مع اندهوفين كمدرب
في انجلترا تحول ريتشارلسون الى ماده
للسخريه على السوشيال ميديا بعد طلقه
انذارا في مباراه فريقه امام ليفربول وكان
البرازيلي قد احرز اول هدف له هذا الموسم
في مسابقه الدوري قبل نهايه البطوله بنحو
5 جولات وجعل المتابعين على مواقع التواصل
يعلقون بان انذارات ريتشارلسون تجاوزت عدد
اهدافه حيث الغي هدفه امام فولو بعدما خلع
قميص احتفالا به مكلفه بطاقه صفراء
مدرب توتينما السابق انطوني كونتي يبدو
انه يستمتع بوقته بعيدا عن ضغط اللاعبين
واداره النادي المدرب الايطالي نشر عبر
حساب على انستغرام صورا له في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس رفقه افراد من عائلته وكان
كنت قد اقيل من تدريب توتنهام عقب
تصريحاته الناريه ضد اداره الفريق ونجومه
ومع اقتراب نابولي من حسم لقب الدوري
الايطالي عادل بلجيكيز الى احتفالي مع
الجماهير باللقب الذي طال انتظاره وكان
مارتنز قد انتقل الى غلطه سرايا التركي
لكنه يملك لقب الهداف التاريخي لنادي
نابولي الذي قضى بين الجدرانه تسع سنوات